when you first boot up a new smash game
there are probably a few characters
you're drawn to first there's Mario you
know him maybe a pic link he's always
there sometimes you pick fox because
you're a furry got all the furries out
there but there's one character that
most players just don't want to touch
the helium voice narcoleptic pink ball
of destruction Jigglypuff in case you've
been living under a rock or in a coma
for the past two decades Jigglypuff is
the balloon pokemon known for her
singing voice that puts enemies to sleep
fun fact though if you don't fall asleep
Jigglypuff will keep singing until it
can no longer breathe and dies that
seems kind of dark isn't Pokemon for
kids excuse me the [__] did you just say
puffs was created in 1996 for the first
Pokemon games that appeared in Super
Smash Brothers in 1999 and hasn't missed
an appearance since during that time
she's only seen the pinnacle of top-tier
once and the fallout from that is
threatening to tear the melee scene
apart puff was something of a joke
character in smash 64 while she shared a
similar kit and nearly identical buttons
with Kirby one of the game's top tiers
it was her special moves that drew
ridicule sing leaves her vulnerable for
an extended time but forces near enough
enemies to fall asleep and rest puts her
to sleep for three seconds sounds pretty
useless right well over time dedicated
puff players learned that if you made
contact with your opponent as you rest
it has a surprisingly devastating effect
there it is
and that's it I remember I use it for
the first time and it's just this
useless [__] mood does 0% you're just
stuck there I'm like she's the worst
picking the game the hour later was
walking down the hall to the bathroom I
turned to the right my brother's room he
happened to playing smash six before and
right and a monkey landed a rest with a
puffing I gave I looked at it and I was
like whoa I'm like how did you do that
he's like yeah just has it that week
that changed that as it turned out
Jigglypuff wasn't actually the worst
character in the game being a poor man's
clone of Kirby and having the explosive
rest was enough to lift puffs from the
tearless basement of smash 64 to its
ground floor and by the time melee
rolled around people still weren't hot
on puff the first tier lists had her at
10 been mine and then 11 in 2004 she
miraculously jumped all the way up to
number 2 it's just too bad the list was
released on in April
basically all the way up to brawls
release in 2008 Jigglypuff at best was a
mid tier character that no one gave the
time of day there were some players who
tried to make her work like eventual
smash god mango but in time he abandoned
the jiggly ship mainly because of the
community's negative response to her but
as the years went on one player found a
way to roll with the punches and make
Jigglypuff an actually viable character
as of right now LAN hungrybox to be Edna
is the best melee player in the world
and he got there by proving the
Jigglypuff wasn't just a legitimate
character but one of my Lee's best
thanks to melees unique mechanics pup is
able to be played much faster than in
other smash games that said despite
being significantly quicker than her
previous incarnation she's still
considered slow by melee standards the
way to deal with that obvious
disadvantage turned out to be slowing
the game down to the point where puffs
speed wasn't as much of a liability that
means running away throwing out her
powerful back air over and over and
being patient while capitalizing on your
opponent's mistakes this safe play style
is the complete opposite of melees
chaotic combat and over the years puff
players like hungrybox have been given a
lot of [__] for playing this way if your
argument is oh there's not that many
puff players
Oh but if puff was broken then everyone
would play her again it would kill the
game people don't play a good puff
because most people don't play melee to
play a floaty slow character that
requires no execution if you think that
it's a violent argument you're an
absolute [__] [__] and you should
not be allowed basic human rights no
that's that's too harsh right editor
don't thank for that one and yet each
box has sharpened a style to the point
where he can impose his will against
faster characters forcing them to play
his slow methodical game back when the
last melee tearless was made in 2015 it
had Jigglypuff at 5th but since then
with the help of hungry boxes incredible
successes there is now an argument that
not only is puff topped here she might
be the best character in the game and
not everyone is happy about that well
then you can't relate to me yes she has
been like been a torture for me for like
faster she's been 17 years if tonight
for a decade
sure she's cute but being on the
receiving end of her wall of back airs
or getting rested on isn't exactly
enjoyable
I'm tired of funny puffs I have to fight
him like at every turn that I go to it's
exhausting and unfun I just don't wanna
do it I wanna do it right now it's even
kicked off a community conversation
about whether or not puff should be
banned but even those that gain spanning
her have gone as far as saying the puff
is so boring that she could be harmful
to the future of the competitive scene
but what if me of fluff or mutes King
start picking puff and we actually beat
hungrybox what would happen if I do that
that every other player is gonna do that
some people say you should do it you
should make every top eight a puff did
oh so that then we can ban puff but that
would be too late by that point the game
would already be dead
and I would have wasted time learning
puff and playing puff dittos literally
torturing myself to eventually just play
a character that gets banned and if the
best character in the game is boring to
watch and play where does that leave
melee even as recently as Genesis 6 a
portion of the audience went as far as
cheering hungrybox during melee top
eight and while his relationship with
the commune
he is complex a lot of the negative
treatment he's received over the years
comes down to puffs and how he
approaches the game
[Applause]
I don't know if you can hear this in my
headset but like listen to the crowd
yeah the crowd is not happy every box is
what are you good at food but it's
reactions like these that even H boxes
greatest rivals feel are unacceptable
I'm basically trying to say hungrybox
deserves more credit and people
discredit him because it's been winning
for so long I don't know and I don't
think I don't think it's puff
I don't think puff is broken
unfortunately respect takes a backseat
to spectacle for some melee fans out
there they want to see the iconic
high-risk gameplay that drew them to the
scene in the first place they don't care
to see what one player has brought to
the table and turned into the most
effective way of playing the game
man so many people hate me why am I
doing this if you leave me I'm not going
any time I have this I'm not just kind
of like stonewalled I can take any BAM
feeling I'd read on stuff but that sucks
and although Jigglypuff exists in other
smash games she's not nearly the problem
she poses in her Gamecube iteration and
with puffs most recent appearance in
smash ultimate it remains to be seen
whether she will reach her melee heights
ever again on one hand she has a nicer
variety of combos into rest and the
overall pace of the game means she
actually gets the press buttons now but
on the other she's still pretty goddamn
slow so mid-tier again the problem is
that people don't want Jigglypuff to be
good
a world where she's top tier is a world
where you can't throw caution to the
wind it's a world of slow methodical
play short combos and long games a world
that the smash community refuses to
accept as their own but whether you like
it or not it's still a viable way to
play the game
puff players like hungrybox carved out a
unique approach to effectively counter
the meta and even though it actually
worked people just can't seem to stop
complaining about it no matter what you
do no matter how good yes I think no
matter how humble you are there will
always be people who hate you
[Applause]
you know for a scene that prides itself
on the principle of no John's it's kind
of sad to see Jigglypuff become the lone
exception to the rule
it means no excuses you know like when
you called in sick for the shoot
yesterday that's a classic John move I'm
not saying your name is John I'm never
mind being a poor man's clone of Kirby
and having the explosive rest was enough
to lift puff from the tearless basement
of smash 64 yeah good idea I'm getting
all choked in here